le printemps a dû son confinement les
tessons déconfinement l'automne son
confinement
en attendant l'hiver est l'heureux
déconfinement on va avoir besoin de
s'occuper un petit peu dtc pense à vous
et vous propose un petit quiz santé pour
animer vos journées vos soirées vos
apéros vision vos nuits d'insomnie en
solo etc
enfin bref de quoi faire de ce
confinement un grand moment de joie et
de bonne humeur
[Musique]
l'érection soir je vous pose une
question je vous fait quatre
propositions de réponses et vous avez 10
secondes pour trouver la bonne dix
secondes ça donne ça allez c'est parti
qu'est ce qu'un hypospadias une zone du
cerveau qui ressemble à un pokémon une
malformation du pénis
une carence en soufre et en phosphore ça
n'existe pas un hypospadias est une
malformation congénitale dans laquelle
l'orifice de l'urètre c'est à dire le
méat qu'on appelle aussi le trou du pipi
il se trouve pas à l'extrémité du gland
mais sur la face inférieure du pénis
c'est à dire en dessous et ci c'est au
dessus ça arrive aussi mais ça s'appelle
un mais pis padiès que se passe-t-il
quand on souffrent d'éjaculation
rétrograde où on a un orgasme en
regardant eric zemmour aux enchères ont
déjà craint avant l'orgasme
on est de la cub dans sa propre récit on
n'a aucune sensation pendant
l'éjaculation
[Musique]
une éjaculation rétrograde c'est une
éjaculation qui se trompe de chemin et
qui va vers la halle et si au lieu
d'aller vers l'extérieur le plus souvent
c'est lié à un problème neurologique qui
empêche le sphincter de la vessie de
fonctionner normalement après une
opération de la prostate par exemple
qu'en dit on qu'on a un site us un
versus quand nos organes ne sont pas à
leur place quand on parle à l'envers
quand on se prend pour un empereur
romain
quand on confond sa gauche et sa droite
[Musique]
le site us en vertu ce ou hétéro taxi
c'est la caractéristique génétique des
personnes qui ont une inversion de
l'emplacement des organes du thorax et
de l'abdomen
c'est à dire qu'ils ont le coeur à
droite le foie à gauche etc
ça touche environ une personne sur
quinze mais à quoi ça sert un massage
cardiaque à faire circuler le sang à
faire repartir le coeur à travailler ses
triceps à stimuler le nerf vague dans le
thorax ont fait un massage cardiaque à
quelqu'un dont le coeur va plus ou en
tout cas plus assez efficacement pour
que le sang circule correctement dans le
corps le but c'est d'appuyer sur le
coeur à travers le thorax pour faire le
travail de pompes qui fait plus tout
seul
et pour que le sang continue de circuler
et d'oxygéner nos différents organes
à quoi ça sert un choc électrique
externe a réveillé la victime à endormir
la victime à régulariser le rythme du
coeur faire repartir le coeur un choc
électrique externe via que dans les
films que ça fait repartir le coeur en
vrai on utilise un défibrillateur quand
le coeur à une activité électrique
irrégulière ou inefficaces ou les deux
en gros un petit coup de jus ça fait un
reset et le coeur se remet à battre
régulièrement après ok mais comment on
fait repartir le coeur alors avec de
l'insuline avec des amphétamines avec
beaucoup d'amour avec de l'adrénaline
[Musique]
le seul moyen de faire repartir le coeur
quand il a plus aucune activité quand le
tracé est plat c'est d'injecter de
l'adrénaline mais ça c'est les secours
qui s'en occupe
vous votre boulot si vous tombez sur
quelqu'un qui en arrêt cardiaque c'est
de faire le massage cardiaque pour faire
circuler le sang en les attendant et de
brancher le défibrillateur automatique
s'il y en a parce que lui il saura si le
coeur a plus aucune activité ou s'il en
a une
inefficace et qu'il faut qu'ils envoient
un choc électrique vous parmi les
personnes suivantes qui est atteint du
syndrome de protée thibault in shape les
3t john merrick et que les tentes man
josette pujol le célèbre que thomas le
syndrome de protée c'est une maladie
génétique qui se caractérise par une
croissance excessive de différents
tissus notamment ceux des eaux de la
peau et des tissus graisseux
le cas le plus célèbre c'est celui de
john merrick aussi appelé elephant man
pas très sympa
le muscle le plus puissant du corps
humain c'est la langue le grand fessier
le muscles de la mâchoire inférieure le
sphincter anal
[Musique]
le muscle le plus puissant du corps
humain c'est pas la langue du rrq la
langue c'est un organe composé de
dix-sept muscles le muscle le plus
puissant c'est le grand fessier ou
grandes luttes et al oud luth et us
maximus ou bon gros bull
il nous sert notamment à va nous tenir
debout et à marcher et à casser des noix
de coco si vraiment on a fait beaucoup
de squatter
quelle est l'origine du mot placebo ça
veut dire ça fait pas de mal
en latin ça veut dire ça fait plaisir en
latin le médecin qui l'a inventé était
fan de brian molko
[Musique]
ça veut dire inutiles on attend placebo
ça vient du latin place et ray qui veut
dire claire être agréable au 19e siècle
ça désigne un médicament qu'on donnait à
un patient pour lui faire plaisir mais
qui le soignent pas vraiment et c'est à
partir du 20e siècle que le mot a été
employé pour désigner les traitements
qu'on utilise dans les essais
comparatifs mais qui n'ont aucun effet
quels symptômes présente les patients
atteints de trim et il a mûri ils
sentent le poisson pourri leur urine et
bleu leur urine et acide il parle en
alexandrins
[Musique]
un patient qui est atteint de trim et il
a mûri il souffre d'un déficit en une
enzyme bien particulière celle qui
permet de dégrader un composant chimique
qu'on appelle la trimestre qui la mine
qui vient lui-même de la dégradation de
certains aliments et qui sent le poisson
pourri du coup la trinity la mine est
s'accumule dans le corps et elle est
éliminée dans la sueur dans l'uriné et
même dans l'haleine on appelle ça aussi
le syndrome de l'odeur du poisson pourri
pas très sainte anne en plus voilà c'est
fini
alors bon j'espère que vous saviez tout
ça mais sans doute pas en tout cas la
bonne nouvelle c'est que maintenant vous
savez c'était un petit peu le but aussi
n'hésitez pas à me donner votre corps
dans les commentaires
sans tricher non parce que je le saurai
de toute façon et dites moi aussi si
vous voulez d'autres quiz comme ça alors
pas tout le temps mais de temps en temps
ça peut être sympa on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien